is an internal audit of your use of FAA
jets for official trips following a
request for review by Senator Marco
Rubio I also can scrutinize Elaine
child's private jet travel as
Transportation secretary do you have a
response to that yeah here's how we
handle my travel the vast majority of
the time I travel on commercial airlines
and economy class but there is a portion
of the time I'd say about 10 to 20
percent when we use our agency's
aircraft this is not chartering a
private jet this is a a government
aircraft that is assigned to the FAA uh
yeah it's private though right meaning
you're the guy that gets on the plane
and there's a pilot and you got your
couple people that work for you and you
do your thing
I'm not against that I'm just calling
out your ridiculous hypocrisy